Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan house
oversight committee chairman that's
James comr and the chairman of the house
Ways and Means Committee Jason Smith
good to see you all uh Jim Jordan let me
start with you let's start with your
letter to Christopher Ray and and then
we'll talk about the
contempt yeah there's an underlying 1023
form uh Sean that was that was earlier
back in 2017 that became the basis for
uh Scott Brady us attorney asking to
talk to the confidential human source
that produced the 1023 form we have so
we've asked Chris Ray to give us that
form but I think when you step back and
look at this week Sean the real big
takeaway wasn't the chaos in Jamie
Comer's committee yesterday wasn't the
fact that Kevin Morris who was sitting
there purchased $875,000 of Hunter
Biden's art and wasn't even what
happened in LA today with Hunter Biden
pleading not Gilly these tax charges I
think the big takeaway is what David
Weiss didn't charge Hunter Biden with he
didn't charge him with those tax years
2014 2015 when he got the income from
barisma in fact he let the statute of
limitations expire because it's one
thing to have a gun charge in Delaware
that doesn't get you to the White House
another thing to have tax charges in La
but the barisma tax years du and that's
what's in that 1023 form that's why they
want the earlier one as well and we've
asked the FBI to produce it when this
became an issue why wouldn't they
automatically have handed out handed you
the the the other 1023 form in other
words were they hiding it from you it
doesn't seem like they're very
Cooperative great question I don't know
they were hiding it from us but we
learned about it when we talked to Scott
uh Brady the US attorney who who Bill
bar charged with filtering all this
stuff and getting it out to the
appropriate US attorneys for
investigation he he he found it out
finally after six months when they
should have turned it over to him he's
the one at asked for it so once we
talked to him we felt we should go
pursue and get this so we're hoping that
Chris Ray will turn it over all right
let's turn to you James comr let's talk
about uh yesterday the antics of Hunter
Biden showing up uh and let's also
explain to people what normal procedure
is if you get a subpoena to appear
before Congress you are deposed that is
behind closed doors and then if there's
a public hearing that would occur
afterward is that not standard procedure
and when Steve Bannon and Peter nvar did
not show up were they not charged with
contempt to Congress after a
recommendation by the
Committees yes that's exactly right
standard procedure you get a subpoena
you come for a deposition you have to
also according to the rules give three
days notice for a deposition to make
sure that everyone's there and
everyone's prepared to ask questions and
to answer questions we've done
everything by the book in this
investigation to ensure that everything
that uh we accumulate in the form of
evidence is accessible and admissible in
a court of law because eventually the
bidens are going to be held accountable
in a court of law hopefully we'll have
this attorney general do their job but
regardless future attorney general will
be able to use the information that we
have obtained in our investigation to
hold these people accountable for the
crimes that they've committed so we did
we did everything by the book Hunter
Biden showed up ironically Sean right
when he sat down uh Moscow wtz from
Florida the Democrat started saying that
Hunter Biden's here he's here to answer
questions he's here to answer questions
and his time expired I recognized
margerie Taylor green she was going to
ask him questions when I recognized
margerie Taylor green Hunter Biden's
eyeballs about popped out and he jumped
up along with Abby LOL and they ran out
and about knocked over three or four
people on the way out the door let's
talk uh Jason Smith let me ask you and
and we'll get an update on what the Ways
and Means Committee uh want to get your
take on the contempt of congress and
whether or not you think that the same
uh laws that were applied to Steve
Bannon and Peter Navar will be applied
to Hunter Biden I think them showing up
yesterday during the middle of this
proceeding was they just they just they
have to have a feeling of confidence
that they're not going to be held to the
same standard I don't have any
confidence that they're going to be held
to the same standard but as we look at
that that two that two-tiered system of
justice my question to you is why
shouldn't Hunter be be treated the same
way as Bannon and
Navaro Sean Hunter should be treated
exactly the same way whenever Steve
Bannon was held in contempt within 22
days the justice department brought
charges against Steve Bannon when Hunter
Biden's held in contempt let's see if
the next 22 days his father's justice
department holds him in content it is
absolutely a great day for the two IRS
whistleblowers Sean because today they
were Vindicated because everything that
they told the house Ways and Means
Committee and the charges that they
thought Hunter Biden should be charged
with in fact that is why he was in court
all nine of them unfortunately as Jim
said he should have also been charged
with 2014 and 15 tax crimes but as The
Whistleblower said the justice
department allowed the statute of
limitations to run out well let's go but
but let me ask you Congressman Smith
this is important here because the
barisma years remember it was David
Weiss in charge was it not and David
Weiss allowed the statute of limitations
to expire is that not true those were
the barisma holding money years okay if
if that happened and David Weiss correct
me if I'm wrong wasn't his original plan
not to charge Hunter and then the
whistleblowers came forward and that led
to the sweetheart deal that blew up in
court because a judge actually read the
agreement and said she'd never seen
anything like this in her life and even
even got the defense to admit they'd
never seen anything like it in their
lives and that only led to David Weiss
finally having the power that he had at
one point said he had and then said he
didn't have uh to go after tax charges
in Washington and and
California that's exactly right Sean
what's interesting is is that this
sweetheart plea agreement the original
one came out two days before the Ways
and Means Committee released the IRS
whistleblower testimony that
whistleblower testimony is what blew up
that sweetheart deal if that sweetheart
deal wouldn't have blown up the charges
would have never came in California and
this would have all been swept
underneath the rug and the two-tier
justice system would have not been seen
they came awfully close Jim Jordan now
the big question is to me this is not
about Hunter Biden to me this is about
Joe Biden Joe Biden that said he never
once spoke to his father uh I'm sorry
his son or brother or anybody for that
matter about their foreign business
dealings Joe Biden that had extensive
contact with foreign business partners
and extensive contact with partners of
his own son regarding financial matters
then it comes to the implication of his
own son on his own laptop in
Communications uh about money Mone is
going to his father at that point are we
talking about you know what are we
talking about here if if a vice
president leverages a billion dollars to
get a prosecutor fired after five days
uh having a phone call with BCE
Executives and his son and his son gets
paid Millions for doing nothing uh with
no experience at a time he's a drug
addict uh what do you call that you call
you call it bribery and what you just
described Sean is the the facts and
Circumstance that took place when Joe
Biden went to
uh Ukraine and conditioned the release
of American Tax dollar Aid to Ukraine on
the firing of the prosecutor who was
applying the pressure to barisma all
that is corroborated by the confidential
human Source he said the confidential
human source told the FBI that the head
of barisma said we hired Hunter Biden to
protect us through his dad that is in
the the prosecutor who they got fired he
conditioned the release of the money on
firing this prosecutor whose name is
Victor shoken he's mentioned eight times
in that 1023 form we're asking now for
the earlier 1023 form so we can put that
information together with us as well
that to me is the really the heart of
this matter and then you have all this
other evidence that Jamie and and Jason
have brought forward from their
committees that support that but the
most corroborating evidence we have is
that 1023 form from this highly credible
confidential human Source according to
us attorney Scott
Brady James comr you have talked a lot
about these shell corporations some 20
of them or however many you might be up
to now uh you talked about 10 Biden
family members you've identified as
getting paid uh we've talked about Joe's
contacts with these for business
partners an official a that he took from
the FD 1023 form which gave us the first
indication which led to the
whistleblowers now we know that there
was no ethics deal at all in terms of uh
Hunter having no knowledge of who was
buying his art but according to the art
dealer he knew who 70% of the buyers
were were they all Democratic
donors uh at least 70% were Democrat
donors we're trying to identify the the
remaining few but at the end of the day
you'll remember Jen saki told everyone
after members of the House oversight
committee demanded that we know who was
actually buying the art she stood up and
said that they had ethics rules in place
they had talked to the art dealer the
art dealer testified under oath in our
interview he's never spoken to anyone at
the White House and he didn't know
anything about an Ethics deal another
lie from the Biden White House all right
we appreciate it James comr Jim Jordan
uh Jason Smith thank you all hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else